mais place maintenant à une aventure
assez extraordinaire celle de fox hard
rock charlie c'est l'un des deux
concorde qui depuis quatre ans et est
immobilisé en bout de piste à l'aéroport
de roissy or face à la demande
croissante des vols charters 450
actuellement programmées et les tours du
monde 8 prévus cette année
air france a qui concorde a rapporté 47
millions de francs l'année dernière et
en france donc a dû remettre en service
fox charlie daniel durand d une équipe
de soir 3 ont suivi la résurrection de
ce supersonique miraculé aéroports de
new york kennedy mardi dernier une
arrivée s'en prend pas aux hawks charlie
après un vol de routine de 3h45
et pourtant on ne donnait pas cher de sa
peau le 14 février 84 il ya quatre ans
lens qu'on essayait de le remiser au
rayon des pièces détachées mais depuis
le développement spectaculaire de la
demande en vols supersoniques et connus
tels que la seule solution première
france était la remise à neuf de son
sixième concors une facture qui dépasse
les 11 mille heures de vol de travail et
le milliard de centimes que la compagnie
nationale estime pouvoir amortir en
moins d'un an et demi la semaine
dernière c'était le vol d'essai après
révision une boucle de trois heures et
demie à mcdo au dessus de l'atlantique
destiné à tester en vrai grandeur le bon
fonctionnement de l'ensemble des
systèmes à l'issue du vol fox charlie
était déclaré une seconde fois dans sa
vie d'avion bon pour le service
cet avion là va nous servir à arrêter
les cinq avions de la flotte
actuellement utilisés ils seront arrêtés
en parrain pour passer ses grandes
visites et nous conservons grâce à cet
avion une flotte vivent 2,5 avions
aéroport de roissy mardi 9 heures du
matin ultimes préparatifs du premier vol
commercial de phoques survie après
quatre ans de mise en sommeil 139 175
184 une visite pré vol de routine comme
avant chaque départ quotidien pour new
york
seule la présence d'une équipe de soir3
abord atteste que ce vol a/r 0,01
mais tout n'est pas tout à fait comme
les autres demandes de trains voyant là
une 4l
vianney 102,3 position du paris sg
je suis presque surpris de ne pas
trouver dans le cockpit quelque chose
d'inhabituel
il me semble que je les ai toujours
reconnues comme il est aujourd'hui
une magnifique image que l'on doit au
travail acharné de 15 mécaniciens d'air
france
pendant plus de six mois
on vient de passer le travers site de
gand vers on est sur le
les provinces maritimes du canada
l'arrivée prévue maintenant dans 45
minutes et il apparaît très bien marché
typique des machines qui dépassera l'an
2000 car en fait comme ici les reposer
pendant quelques années il arrivera en
l'an 2000 avec encore suffisamment de
potentiel pour des pas prêt
landreville et je pense que charlie sera
certainement le dernier a porté jeudi
les européens et des français surtout
pendant le quart de siècle